en varias ocasiones te ha hablado de
cómo usar un poli 9 para aproximar una
función lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es mostrarte cómo es que esto
sucede para esto usar el sitio
wolframalpha un sitio donde pueden ser
toda clase de locura matemática
wolframalpha puntocom el sitio donde
sacado esta imagen y la he pegado para
que trabajemos sobre ella recientemente
me encontré con stephen wolfram en una
conferencia quien me dijo adelante
puedes usar wolframalpha en tus vídeos y
es súper útil pues si bien puedes hacer
esto con una calculadora gráfica paso a
paso con wolfram alta lo puedes hacer de
un solo jalón veremos ahora cómo
aproximar la función seno de x por medio
de lo que se conoce como expansión en
serie más gloria o expansión en serie de
taylor alrededor de x igual a 0 usando
cada vez más términos apreciaremos
visualmente el hecho de que entre más
términos tengamos mejor es la
aproximación a seno de x
veamos la gráfica aquí en naranja
tenemos seno de x una vieja conocida
nuestra
en vídeos previos hemos visto cuál es la
expansión de mag loring para seno de x
wolframalpha también lo hace para
nosotros
de hecho desarrolla los factoriales 3
factoriales 65 factoriales 120 y así
sucesivamente lo que es interesante es
que tú puedes elegir cuántas
aproximaciones vas a utilizar lo que se
hace entonces es eliminar términos en
este caso nos quedamos sólo con el
primer término el polinomio es igual a
equis y esta es la curva que lo
representa nos damos cuenta de esto por
estos puntos que se encuentran en la
recta algo que es realmente ingenioso
así es que esta de aquí es p de x igual
a x la aproximación es burda sin embargo
cerca de cero vemos que la recta está
encima de la curva del seno de x para
posteriormente separarse
agreguemos otro término ahora lo que la
función resulta x - x cúbica sobre 6
tendremos ahora dos términos aunque más
bien en lo que hay que enfocarnos es que
ahora tenemos un término de orden 3 aquí
teníamos el polinomio de orden 1 x a la
1 lo que se veía como un punto en la
gráfica y ahora tenemos el término x
cúbica sobre 6 polinomio de orden 3 no
tuvimos un término cuadrática es decir
no tuvimos un polinomio orden 2 y
tuvimos directamente un polinomio de
orden 3 veamos qué sucede en la gráfica
buscamos los tres puntos sobre la curva
teníamos originalmente el problema de
orden uno que es esta línea recta y
ahora que hemos sagrado el término - x
cubica sobre 6 tenemos esta curva que es
el polinomio de orden 3 y fíjate qué
pasa ahora empieza la curva a abrazar
seno de x un poquito antes y la deja un
poquito después de donde lo hizo la
primera aproximación así es que al
agregar este segundo término hay una
mejor aproximación sobre todo para
valores cercanos a 0 agregamos otro
término entonces tenemos ahora un
polinomio de orden 5 x - x cúbicas sobre
6 más x quinta sobre 120 buscamos ahora
la curva de 5 puntos 1 2 3 4 5 esta es
la curva y notemos como la curva abraza
seno de x poquito antes que lo que lo
hizo cuando teníamos los términos y
continúa y la continúa abrazando un
poquito después de lo que lo hizo la
curva anterior
vamos a agregar ahora otro término
agregamos el cuarto término es x a la
séptima entre cinco mil cuarenta y
estamos entonces trazando la curva de
orden 7 de la curva viene por aquí y
observamos que monta la curva seno de x
antes de lo que lo hizo con los tres
términos anteriores sigue por aquí y
sigue sobre la curva todo el trayecto
todo el trayecto hasta aquí y el último
término si tienes todos estos términos
hasta el término x está la novena
empieza la curva por aquí y abraza la
curva antes y sale un poquito después de
lo que le hicieron las curvas anteriores
que está pasando aquí cada término que
estamos agregando a la serie es un
término que tiene un orden cada vez
mayor de equis dividido entre un número
que es cada vez más grande así es que
para valores pequeños de x valores cerca
del origen este denominador va a
sobrepasar el numerador especialmente
cuando el número es menor a 1 porque
cuando tienes un número cuyo valor
absoluto es menor a 1 al elevar una
potencia este número se reduce
así que cerca del origen estos últimos
términos no importan tanto por así
decirlo no pierden la precisión de los
primeros términos cuando estos términos
exorbitantes aparecen lo hacen cuando el
numerador empieza a superar al
denominador si es que cuando este
término aparece lo hace cuando empieza a
ser dominante aquí en esta zona de acá
cuando x a la novena supera a 382 1880 y
lo mismo sucede para valores negativos
espero que con esto te haya quedado
claro aquí sólo tenemos uno dos tres
cuatro o cinco términos imagina que lo
que sucede cuando tenemos una infinidad
de términos creo que ya tienes una idea
de que por así decirlo se va a montar en
la curva de seno de x hasta el infinito
espero que esto te haya quedado claro y
puedes para entretenerte un rato y de
wolfram alpha puntocom y teclear mayor
en expansión o taylor expansión para
seno de equis o coseno de x alrededor de
x igual a cero puedes probar con varias
funciones y visualizar así puedes
agregar o quitar términos para ver cómo
la expansión de la serie se monta en la